we want you to know christ that peace
with him so please ma'am turn away this
is the front line of america's abortion
wall jason storms his wife and their 10
children are picketing this clinic in
milwaukee please take a piece of
literature there's a lot of places where
you can get help they briefly have some
interest from a woman going into an
appointment
storms is the leader of operation save
america an evangelical pro-life group
and his views are extreme no gay
marriage no morning after pill and
certainly no abortion
i think that life begins at
fertilization i think our laws should be
clear that little human beings
are made in the image of god they have
value from the moment that they come
into existence coming down here though
you're trying to influence
women who may very well have thought
very hard
about what they're doing
do you understand that some people might
view that as
misogynistic and anti-democracy thinking
very hard and thinking properly are two
different things right
what we want to do is
have the debate
the cultural tension is there let's
discuss it but you don't believe in the
right to choose i support the right to
choose i don't support the right to kill
innocent babies in the womb
to terminate a pregnancy yeah 12 weeks
are a functioning baby they can smile
for jason's children standing outside
these clinics is routine i need you to
understand that the women that you're
yelling at are also vulnerable on the
other side a local pastor fearful of the
right to choose being stripped away
it means a world in which
rights and access to health care are
selective based on where you live and
the whims of your state legislature i'm
very worried about what will happen
especially to poor and black and brown
women
who don't have access to other options
in the way that for instance wealthy
white women always will in this country
sprinkle around the storm's children are
home schooled they come to this farm in
rural wisconsin to learn about the land
and living a simple life
and for 18 year old julia even the issue
of abortion is black and white what
about if a woman has been
abused and raped or forced against her
yeah
you know i like to say two wrongs don't
make a right
and that child is just as much of a
victim as the mother is they didn't
choose to be in that position the child
doesn't have any less value than a child
who was conceived
consensually
mother sarah agrees that abortion should
be outlawed in almost every case as a
mum of
seven girls a woman yourself yes
that actually women have been given
freedom to choose if abortion is the
reason why
is that the freeing aspect of women that
they can i think it's just the right to
choose over your own body this isn't
your own body this is a unique created
individual created in god's image
the storm's family's views are
absolutely and belie the complex issues
at hand many will vehemently disagree
and with america on the brink of a
seismic shift in life and law that
divide will only deepen martha kellner
sky news wisconsin